upbringing the accommodations for the
out of town guests and such and so now I
will hand things over to Umesh we'll
give a little introductory remarks to
the workshop
thanks Andy uh welcome everyone uh so
since um I mean most of you are all
hands here but um but I guess many of
you are here just for this Workshop so
I'll say a little bit about
Quantum and Simons and also this
Workshop so
um I uh you know uh I'm sure many of you
know there's uh that that we run
something called the quantum research
board here at the Simons Institute which
is uh you know a continuous presence of
people who work in Quantum Computing you
know there are a number of postdocs
visitors students Etc who who are here
on a permanent basis and then in
addition to that we have we run summer
clusters like like the one that this
Workshop is a part of this summer and
there's an upcoming program next spring
um which is actually a co-location of
coding Theory and two programs one
encoding Theory and one in Quantum
computation
um so again uh you know if you're not
already participating there they are
going to be several workshops during
that semester and you're you're welcome
to to participate
um I should say a little bit about about
this summer cluster it's it's been
funded by NSF and doe as part of this
National Autumn initiative and
part of the uh of the rationale for this
is is
um actually
um
to um to have closer ties between
Quantum Computing and the and the
computer science Community the
theoretical computer science Community
now anybody who has that should should
be a little startled because of course
theoretical computer science was right
at the heart of the beginning of quantum
Computing uh so what does it mean closer
ties between theoretical computer
science community and and Quantum
Computing well I I guess the point is
that there's a there's a real barrier to
entry um for for computer scientists to
go into this field because of having to
learn about quantum mechanics but on the
other hand this uh you know this um uh
the the the reasons to try have have
become now almost almost impossible to
resist so for example the the ties
between Quantum Computing and
cryptography are now so deep that it's
it's really hard to imagine working in
the field without without understanding
uh these these connections or if you
look at stps and you know the connection
to Quantum and complexity theories you
know again uh again very very uh very
deep and interesting or you know if you
look at algorithms for linear algebra
again there's there's there are these uh
deep connections so so what the Simon's
Institute has been trying to do is to is
to sort of uh provide a catalyst for
bringing bringing these uh these
together and there's another aspect of
this um of what it's trying to do which
is which is to also nurture uh
connections between between Quantum
Computing uh you know uh from the
computer science side and physics and
chemistry and Mathematics and um okay so
maybe you'll see some of the themes here
in this Workshop so each of the days is
designated to be a different topic we've
tried to keep the keep the workshop
extremely relaxed you know with with uh
only four talks a day each an hour long
and with lots of breaks so some of you
you may remember very few of you may
remember that the first workshop at the
Simons Institute was on Quantum
Computing back in 2013 maybe
and uh and there we have this rule uh
saying that discussion trumps schedule
so
um you know so that has two us two two
components to it one is that
you should feel free to interrupt and
ask questions uh you know there's each
each session has a moderator a session
chair who would who will stop you if
it's if you're going too far off on a
tangent but then it also comes with a
promise to the speaker saying that you
know any amount of time that goes into
these questions and answering them is
not taken out of their time you'll just
let the schedule
sort of
you know slip as need be okay so a
discussion is more important than
keeping the trains running on times is
the is the mean okay so
um you know as um as Sandy pointed out
bill has done some of the heavy lifting
on putting the workshop together what
she failed to mention is that she's one
of the organizers of this program and of
the workshop so it was uh Sunday and um
and uh and and of course bill so Bill's
sharing the session so I'll hand it over
too
foreign
chair
um like Uma said each day has a
particular theme and uh today's theme is
all about Quantum advantage and uh
Quantum benchmarking and uh you know of
course it's it's really hard to imagine
getting started with a in a sort of a
better place than to have Scott Aronson
from uh UT Austin uh sort of a seminal
figure in the field of course tell us
about his wish list for a verifiable
nisk experiments all right well uh thank
you so much uh Sandy Andrew mash and
Bill uh and it's always uh uh a pleasure
to be able to be here at assignments and
um uh this uh image I I asked you know I
I I I I I I I I I I now uh work for open
AI of course so I had to ask Dolly you
know what what is what is your solution
to verifiable nisk Advantage I'm not you
know this was uh its answer I'm not sure
if there's any insight to be gleaned
from it uh but um you know this this
talk is is less a talk of like here's
you know the like uh some difficult
results that I prove that I'm proud of
and uh uh that I want to you know show
you or brag about I mean you know there
will be there will be some results but
mostly you know this is a talk of here
is what I would like you to do you know
while I'm off you know trying to save
the world from the robot apocalypse or
whatever okay you know you know that you
know the you know the truly important
stuff like Quantum complexity Theory you
know still needs to happen and so here
here is what you know I would I would
like to see happen and so it's sort of a
research program uh which which any of
you can have free of charge
um
uh so um
so I know that most of you know this but
just to sort of briefly you know recap
where are we on the quest to demonstrate
uh Quantum Supremacy or Quantum
advantage or whatever you uh prefer to
call it uh so um you know uh let's say
13 years ago uh uh you know some of us
uh including you know Bremner Jose and
Shepard uh independently me and Alex
archipov uh you know had the the
realization that if your goal is just to
demonstrate a speed up via a quantum
computer uh you know as as soon as
possible uh then you know uh uh uh you
you sort of don't want uh uh something
like Shores factoring algorithm you know
that we'll uh uh you know clearly
require a a fault tolerant hardware and
that you know we uh uh uh can't
um Implement you know we uh we don't
know how to implement yet uh what what
you probably want to do is a sampling
task okay a task that does not have a
single right answer uh like like
factoring okay where the desired output
is a sample from a probability
distribution okay and you can design
problems like that that are you know
extremely close to the native Hardware
right that are you know that don't
require very expensive encodings uh and
then you're sort of playing a game of
you know you get to uh shoot an arrow
and then sort of draw the Target around
where it landed right you don't care
which specific
distribution you're sampling from as
long as it is some distribution that you
can characterize and that you can
demonstrate that you are say sampling
from it and you can give evidence that
doing the same thing with a classical
computer would be hard okay so uh uh so
uh you know there are two main types of
experiments of this form uh that have
been uh uh actually done on a large
scale you know over the last four years
or so
um the first of these uh actually for
the first one to be achieved uh
experimentally was random circuit
sampling uh which you know in in the way
that we we now wreck in time was uh
announced by Google just just just
before the pandemic and
um uh they built a superconducting
device with uh called Sycamore with 53
qubits actually 54 but one of them
didn't work uh you know in a rectangular
array and they have a nearest
controllable near neighbor couplings so
they have two Cubit gates in in these
sorts of patterns and then all they do
is they start with the qubits and the
zero State and they apply a random
circuit okay but they apply the same
random circuit over and over again and
uh you know and then each time they
measure and you get some they get a
sample from some probability
distribution over 53-bit strings okay
and um
and they repeat that millions of times
and they collect a lot of data and then
they have the problem of how do you
validate that right how do you know that
your quantum computer did anything
interesting okay and so we're going to
talk a lot about the problem of
validation which is really key to this
entire Enterprise okay and then but then
uh the you know the the the the the
second question of course which is which
is also key is uh well was there you
know however you you whatever validation
test you're using you know could a
classical computer have have passed that
test as well could a classical computer
have spoofed it okay and you know
there's been a lot of discussion back
and forth about that question uh you
know and these problems are not as hard
for a classical computer as it turns out
as as one might have originally hoped
they were okay but you know if your goal
was to solve this this sort of bizarre
sampling problem I think that you know
there are there are still you know a
couple orders of magnitude advantage to
actually doing it with a quantum
computer as opposed to doing it by by
any currently known classical method
it's not clear whether that will
continue to be true okay so you could
say you know we still you know we have
Quantum Supremacy quote unquote but it's
sort of hanging by a thin thread and uh
you know there is an urgent need to do
better okay now uh the you know the the
other type of experiment that we've seen
over the past few years you know during
the pandemic actually uh was a a large
scale experiments in boson sampling uh
this was the thing that you know
archipov and I originally proposed in
2011. it's where you generate a bunch of
photons you send them through a network
of uh beam Splitters and phase shifters
so just simple linear Optical elements
and then you just measure uh you have a
bunch of photo detectors that you know
that say uh uh like in each output mode
either you know is there a photon there
how many photons are there uh and so you
get a sample from a probability
distribution over all of the possible
places where the photons could have been
gone
um
and uh uh the uh uh surprise the people
was that this you know simple linear
Optical setup even without feed forward
measurements or anything like that you
know it's almost certainly it's not a
universal quantum computer or even a
universal classical computer for that
matter uh but uh if you look at you know
how hard would it be to simulate
classically you know we could give an
argument that uh that well at least at
least to do it perfectly seems to be
very very hard uh uh argument related to
the fact that linear Optical amplitudes
are the permanence of of matrices uh n
by n matrices if you've got n photons
and the permanent is a sharp P complete
problem in in complexity Theory okay so
we're not saying we weren't saying that
boson sampling itself lets you solve a
sharp P complete problem like that would
be too good to be true but because the
permanent is Sharpie complete uh uh uh
you know you can use that to our argue
for why even just simulating the
sampling task that this device is doing
seems to be classically hard okay so
again
um there there's been a very interesting
interaction here where at first you know
the team uh
um
um at ustc in in in in jefe in China uh
led by Chao Yang Liu uh uh announced in
in in 2020 that they could do boson
sampling uh or a variant called gaussian
boson sampling with about a hundred
photons on average and you know and that
you know they did not know how to
simulate the results classically uh and
since then the group at Xanadu in
Toronto has also done a boson sampling
experiment which improves uh over usdc's
in that it has uh controllable beam
Splitters and also uh they can they can
actually count how many photons are in
each output mode rather than just uh
saying you know is is the number zero
we're non-zero
um
now uh there's also been uh uh you know
people trying to simulate these
experiments classically and uh you know
uh including some you know people in
this room who've worked on that problem
and uh we might we might hear more about
it and uh you know it's I would say that
it's not clear if if we have Quantum
Supremacy right now with boson sampling
uh you know one of the big engineering
problems is that a large fraction of the
photons get lost as they're traveling
through the beam splitter Network and it
would be much much easier to you know uh
argue for the the classical hardness of
what is going on uh uh uh uh if if if if
we could do this without so many lost
photons
um
yes
just count the time for the particular
task and that's it yeah so I so so so so
so so you know the you know we should we
should be clear that this is a a soft
Criterion like it is a thing that like
you you know you you could be in a world
where it's definitely not achieved you
could be in a world where it definitely
is achieved like no matter how you look
at it but you could also be in like you
know the the BPP intermediate regime
where you can't be in the changing world
that's right that's right that's right
and you know you could even have Quantum
Supremacy be achieved and then
unachieved because the classical you
know uh computers get stronger right so
fundamentally you know we're asking for
something negative right we're asked you
know there is not a fast fast algorithm
to do this and classical Computing can
fight back I mean so this is a
fundamental difficulty and I feel like
right now we are right in the middle of
the sort of the the the the the the BPP
you know intermediate error when you
know you can still you know it depends
what you mean and you can argue about it
um you know now now if you look at let's
say the the
um the the superconducting you know the
random circuit sampling experiments I
think that uh uh you know if you uh you
know like like you know so so you can
always simulate them Faster classically
by just using More chords right so this
is this is the fundamental difficulty in
using wall clock time you know as your
as your measure right you can always
just you know pay more into AWS or
whatever right just you know buy more
you know parallel processors right and
you know and and the the simulation
methods that we know are all highly
parallelizable right and so so you so
you can always reduce the classical Time
by just spending more and more uh uh
processors but you know then you could
compare the amount of energy right and
you know the the you know uh uh a
superconducting quantum computer like
this one is not exactly you know uh
green right it it uses a you know a
dilution refrigerator right which is you
know the size of a closet and which is
you know pretty energy expensive but if
you you know um um
you know actually you know uh John
Martinez and I you know tried to run the
numbers and I think that there's you
know looks like there's at least a
factor of a hundred you know compared to
you know if you wanted to simulate this
classically with like the best uh uh
with the best known algorithms and
reproduce the same linear cross entropy
score right we know very fast algorithms
like there was a Barack it all that
would get a worse linear cross entropy
score but if you want the same one you
know as I said there seems to still be
an advantage albeit a tenuous one yeah
yeah
people are traveling this way of looking
at things where you say well you know uh
Quantum Supremacy you achieve it you
unachieve it it sort of depends upon
that you wake up on you know it depends
on sort of
they find margins yes of course I've
never seen it like that you know are we
the Google experiment was plausibly you
know you know you could sort of make a
case that maybe the other Chief wasn't
Supremacy at the time is that it was
announced and that was great you know I
think that's a that's a fine thing to
claim
I I think that uh you know when one
thinks about quality Supremacy one means
look the margins are so great that
borrowing a revolution in our in you
know so for instance
okay great all that stuff right so but
uh change in you know some some sort of
revolutionary change and understanding
of the field we've achieved
yeah so I mean I mean I mean of course
it's troubling but you know at some
point it's a terminological issue right
like I I I I didn't like the term you
know Quantum Supremacy when it was for
right it sounded to self-aggrandizing
you know when I first heard it and then
you know and then you know you know
people said that you should stop using
it then I felt like okay well then I
will use it but but
but but uh uh you know I mean I mean you
you could say you know maybe it's all
you know this is all clear or if we just
say Quantum Advantage right you know you
know there there is a you know there
seems to be an advantage if your goal
was to solve you know random circuit
sampling or you know get a high linear
cross-entropy Benchmark right there
seems to be a you know a a modest
advantage to using the device the
advantage is marginal you know one more
Improvement in the classical algorithms
and it could be gone on the other hand
you know we could probably with today's
technology we could do a much better uh
random circuit sampling experiment so
yeah I would propose that yeah you know
you know as you said the the term
quantum Supremacy seems uh you know
based on so let's keep it strong and say
look you know you don't achieve it and
let's say Quantum advantage means
exactly what you said but you know uh if
we think that there's an Xbox
what was your problem
architecture which was kind of give rise
to an Universal quality so their claim
was Stronger Justin
but they did they did an architecture
which had controlled opportunities which
could lead to a universal quantum
computer
I agree you know and that that is part
of the story here is that they're saying
that a universal quantum computer can
achieve Advantage not just a random
physicist I agree no it's not the part
of the story that I was focusing on but
but it is an important part yes okay all
right so so just to be a little bit more
precise what you know what was the the
random circuit sampling proposal uh you
uh challenge the quantum computer by
sending it a randomly generated circuit
C on N qubits uh then you ask the
quantum computer to send back to you
quickly a bunch of uh what what ought to
be independent samples call them S1 up
to S Sub K from a distribution uh that
we'll call d sub c right which is just
the distribution Over N bit strings that
you obtain by applying C to the all zero
initial State okay so now this is a
distribution you know that that depends
on the circuit you know given enough
time you could compute it if you knew
the circuit okay and it's not the
uniform distribution right it has a
little in homogeneities in it okay
because some amplitudes are a little bit
bigger and some are a little bit smaller
right to some randomly enjoyed more
constructive interference and others
suffered more destroy destructive
interference in fact the amplitudes look
like uh in you know IID gaussian random
variables more or less okay and so what
that means is the probabilities they're
all exponentially small you know with
overwhelming probability but they're not
all equally exponentially small okay
some of them might be two over two to
the N others might be only a half over
two to the n and so forth and those in
homogeneities are the main thing that
we're interested in okay now how do we
detect them
oh yeah so so so we use a staggered
pattern like this in our random circuit
to make sure that every uh qubit can
influence every other one and then
um what we do is uh what became known as
the linear cross entropy Benchmark even
though it's not actually about entropy
uh uh uh so we we uh using our knowledge
of c and using our classical computer we
calculate this sum here okay so uh so
for each of the observed outputs S1 S2
and so forth we calculate what would
have been the probability that an ideal
quantum computer would have produced
that as output and then we just sum all
of those probabilities up okay and if
the sum exceeds a certain threshold then
we say that you know the experiment
succeeded and otherwise not okay so now
what should that threshold be well
um you know the clearly the average
probability is 2 to the minus n
is that you know they add up to one uh
so if we just pick the sis uniformly at
random we'd expect the sum to be about K
over 2 to the N okay and so now the key
question is are we exceeding that and by
how much are we exceeding it right and
now you can do a calculation that says
if you had an ideal quantum computer
than what you would expect for this sum
is that it would be about 2k over 2 to
the N okay so that you would you would
you know satisfy this inequality with b
equal to two Okay and again with just
trivial you know uh coin flipping you
would achieve b equal to one right and
so now what Google achieved in its
experiment in 2019 was b equal to
1.002 okay so you know it's a situation
it's actually very very analogous to the
violation the experiments that violated
the Bell inequality you know starting 40
years ago Okay so you have the ideal
Quantum value that you sort of you know
you know that you can't achieve you have
the trivial classical value that's you
know not not interesting to achieve and
you're trying to just achieve exceed the
classical value by even just a little
bit and thereby you know hopefully rule
out any secretly classical explanation
for what was observed
okay
so okay but now you know what is wrong
with the current experiments well we
already talked about this somewhat but
you know okay the obvious problem you
could say is that the lack of error
correction you know in our device sort
of prevents scaling it up to to to the
regime where you know the quantum
Advantage would really be unambiguous
where we wouldn't have to squint and
argue about it anymore okay so uh right
now you know uh uh you know you can uh
in in Google's experiment they did two
qubit gates with maybe 99.8 Fidelity
okay uh apparently now you can do a two
qubit gate with 99.9 Fidelity and oh no
sorry Google maybe had 99.5 yeah so I'm
sorry it's all right and then it more
recently it got up to 99.8 and then 99.9
which is part of why I say that you know
a much better random circuit sampling
experiment could be done right now and
then there was there was done a few
years ago
um
but uh uh the um um you know you know
then then you're applying about you know
a thousand of these Gates and because
there's no error correction you know the
total circuit Fidelity you know falls
off exponentially right with you know it
goes down and down with each with each
new gate that you apply uh in Google's
experiment there was maybe you know on
the order of a thousand Gates uh and you
know scientifically one of the most
interesting things that we learned from
the Google experiment was that the total
circuit Fidelity seemed to scale simply
like the gate the Fidelity of it one
individual gate raised to the power of
how many gates there are right and so
you know they're they're you know if
there are some sort of uh uh
conspiratorial correlations that push
the Fidelity down further then we we
seem to see no sign of it okay and this
is this is interesting enough that Gil
kalai for example still does not believe
it right and and he basically you know
has a 40 page paper saying like this is
impossible there must have been you know
something wrong with the experiment
because that's just you know too good to
be true
um so you know but in the meantime you
know not only Google but also you know
usdc and I believe you know IBM and
others have now replicated it so
um
uh so um okay but you know uh having
said that as long as the the circuit
Fidelity is going down exponentially
with the number of gates then you can
see that you're sort of inherently
limited right you know you could do 50
qubits you know maybe you could do 100
qubits right uh uh and uh but uh but you
know you can't do uh you can't do
millions of gates on thousands of qubits
uh because because if you do then then
what you get out at the end will just be
indistinguishable from the uniform
distribution okay uh and so now the you
know so this is sort of what limits us
right you're you're you know you're
limited to let's say you know 50 Q 60 70
qubits uh you know maybe 20 or 30 layers
of gates and in that regime you know you
can be clever you can do you know
classically a little bit better than
Brute Force at simulating these things
or you know even even a lot you know
still exponential time but a lot better
than brute force and you know if you're
clever enough then you may be able to uh
defeat the claim of of quantum Advantage
uh but you know to my mind though
there's an even deeper problem than that
which is that even if you could scale
you know even if we had suppose we had
Hardware that was good enough that we
could scale to hundreds of qubits and
you know thousands of layers of gates uh
even then it's still not clear how we
would do the random circuit sampling
experiment because we wouldn't know how
to verify the result
okay uh you know the verification of the
result using this linear cross entropy
Benchmark right requires that we
calculate you know this number here
right which means we have to calculate
the sum right and that you know seems to
be hard for a classical computer for
exactly the same reasons why we believe
that spoofing the experiment is hard
right and so the verification and the
spoofing are Thai RR are are linked to
each other right and so you can't go
completely beyond the the realm where
you know a classical computer would have
any hope of spoofing you because if you
did then you would also be completely
Beyond The Realm where you have any hope
of verifying the results
okay so that's really an inherent
problem with this type of experiment
um
and and so so so you know what I think
has emerged over the last couple of
years as maybe sort of the central you
know near-term challenge for Quantum
Computing theory is you know can you
solve that can you get a sort of uh a a
a
um a a so so so so so you could say that
what we want is a Quantum speed up that
has three properties simultaneously okay
so let's let's let's let's go through
these okay this is this is this is this
this this is how I think about you know
sort of the uh what what I what I would
like to be you know a central research
agenda for the field okay uh we want a
Quantum speed up which on the one hand
is nisky nisk is a not you know of
course means noisy intermediate scale
Quantum you know uh uh is a term that
John presco coined six years ago uh you
know and and again you know like Quantum
Supremacy it's not exactly clear what
it's definition is but you could say you
know we sort of know it when we say it
right or you know we or rather we know
it when we implement it okay you know
nisk means we can actually things that
we can actually do on quantum computers
that will be available you know now or
in the next few years and that do not
require error correction or or at most
only very very minimal error correction
okay uh uh and then the second thing is
of course at least in principle we would
like a Quantum Advantage which means we
need some argument uh or or you know uh
some evidence that there is not a fast
classical algorithm to do the same thing
okay uh and then the third thing that we
want is the one that I just talked about
okay that we want uh uh an experiment
where a classical computer can
efficiently verify the output where we
don't have to do an exponential time
classical computation you know like to
to calculate a linear cross entropy
score or something like that and
therefore there is at least the
potential that we could scale the
experiment up to hundreds of qubits you
know as are available on on some of the
latest devices
okay and my claim is that is that our uh
uh our our our knowledge right now is
that basically we know how to achieve
any two of these three uh requirements
okay so if you ask for something that is
nisky and has an in-principle Quantum
Advantage then you know that's exactly
the you know the current generation of
uh of of sampling based Quantum
Supremacy experiments you know boson
sampling random circuit sampling things
like that uh if you ask for
um something that that you know uh has
an in principle Quantum advantage and is
efficiently verifiable well I mean those
were some of the seminal early
discoveries of the field you know
Shore's algorithm you know presumably
gives you that right you know the uh uh
the solution to factoring or discrete
log is efficiently verifiable those are
NP problems uh but you know there are
other things in this in this uh uh uh uh
region as well right and you you know
there were breakthrough recent protocols
for taking arbitrary Quantum
computations and making them uh
verifiable by a classical skeptic using
cryptography and using interactive
protocols okay the big breakthrough was
was that of Irma lamahadev and there's
been a lot of work since then uh
building on that you know trying to make
it more practical and you know maybe
someday that will get to the nisk era
but you know or be implementable on this
device but I think that we're not there
yet
um yeah
exactly consistent with your definition
of Supremacy because
from Advantage okay you know if you if
you look at Advantage as at a given
point a given task is you know a Quantum
Computing wins over classical
yeah you don't need scalability
well well okay I mean I I would say that
I I kind of want both things I want to
see that well okay I would I would say
that I I actually I want I want three
things okay because I should have had a
slide about this but I want you to to be
a classical computer you know in the
most concrete sense of you know just
just you know here here's the numbers
here's the resources the energy the time
that we needed right and we are winning
okay I want it to be for a general
problem where we believe that there is
an asymptotic speed up and thirdly I
want the explanation the only available
explanation of number one to make
reference to number two okay so I want
the real world speed up that you're
you've observed in practice to be in
some sense because you are solving a
problem that has an asymptotic Quantum
speed and then why tie the two things
together I mean you could imagine
Quantum Advantage being shown
um as evidence for a scalable Quantum
Supremacy
the constants are still
um you know in favor of the classical
computer you could you could I mean I
mean I mean I mean that would be a
weaker thing to aim for you know and and
then uh uh uh you know uh uh you know
the the the the the the Skeptics will
then endlessly make fun of you but you
know I mean you know you could you could
right I mean like like yes you could you
know that you know along the way toward
achieving this you could achieve that
weaker thing I'm just I'm just setting
my sights a little bit higher than that
so
um
uh yeah so okay so now now a third thing
in this in this intersection might be
you know physics simulations where here
the verification would not be you know
because the problem is and P is nnp
necessarily or because of Any clever
interactive protocol uh but rather it
would be because you can take the result
of your Quantum simulation and compare
it to experiment you can compare it to
you know what is actually the rate of
this chemical reaction or what is
actually the you know uh uh uh magnetic
susceptibility of this material right
and you could see if your simulation is
is is is matching experiment okay so so
you know I have I have some optimism
that that that something here might be
doable in the NASCAR uh but then if we
ask for uh the intersection of these two
bubbles something that is nisky and
efficiently verifiable you know I would
say that that uh uh you know the uh you
know all the you know the work that
there's been over the past decade on on
sort of nist quantum optimization
methods such as the qaoa uh uh uh or you
know vqe and various you know Quantum
machine learning algorithms I would say
if we could be confident that they are
beating a classical computer at some
task then you know this then this would
get us to where we wanted right I think
the challenge here is of course to to uh
as as as as people working on these
things very well know is is to get a
clear you know speed up over classical
okay so so you know just just looking at
this uh diagram you know gives us three
you know obvious strategies for sort of
trying to get into the center of this of
this Venn diagram we could start with
the you know heuristic uh um algorithms
for optimization and machine learning
problems like qaoa and we could try to
you know show or find find the the the
problems on which they give us a clear
Quantum Advantage uh if there are such
problems uh we could uh start with you
know uh protocols including you know
cryptograph
cryptography based protocols or physics
simulations uh that we're pretty sure
you know give us a a verifiable and
scalable Quantum advantage and find a
way to implement these on a list of them
device but you know I would say right
now a big difficulty is that anything
that involves doing cryptography on a
superposition over inputs okay anything
that looks like that you know that if
I'm doing number Theory or lattice
computations or anything of that kind
incoherent superposition seems like it
is beyond what we can do on a nist
device right now okay I think that some
further Insight or optimization will be
needed to change that situation okay but
that's the that's the second thing and
then the third thing is like the one I
guess that I personally thought about
the most uh
could we take the kinds of quantum uh uh
uh Supremacy experiments that are
already successful you know that we
already know how to do and figure out a
way to make them efficiently classically
verifiable do you treat them as in
principle Quantum Advantage still
um yes in principle
yes by the the
despite what he said in the beginning
you know I mean I mean because you know
uh all of the efficient classicals you
know simulations that we know sort of
use the way in which these experiments
are imperfect very weights right they
use you know the fact that the the
Fidelity is is you know is perfect is
imperfect or that in the case of boson
sampling that many of the photons are
lost you know yeah right I mean I mean
the the ideal versions of these
experiments you know we're still quite
confident that you know they they you
know there should be a scalable Quantum
Advantage there
so
um
all right so so I've been I've been
thinking about you know I don't have a
solution to this but you know I I have
at least a research program that looks
you know of problems that look like one
could make progress on them and that
would give us new in you know a very
relevant new information about about
this problem so I wanna I wanna tell you
what my new open questions are okay so
let me call a Quantum circuit peaked
you know what
I think
yeah yeah thing yeah all right yeah all
right let me call off Quantum circuit
peaked uh I was just checking if people
were paying attention Okay uh if if
um
if it has the property that uh uh there
is some uh output there's some string X
that c outputs with a very large
probability like let's say at least one
tenths when
what if C is the identity then it would
be peaked with x equal to the all zero
string being being the string on which
it is p yes it is easy to give examples
of peak circuits right okay uh uh good
uh thank you Eddie uh uh uh uh so so you
know now now what what what one could
give a more general definition what I
really care about here is just does the
output does the state gen produced by C
so C 0 to the N does it have sort of any
features that are that make it easy to
distinguish from just the maximally
mixed state or just you know let's say a
horror random State okay okay uh but you
know this this would be one of the
simplest examples of such a feature
right if it has a very you know a a
noticeable probability on a single
string when it is measured in the
standard basis okay so now uh uh let me
ask the following question okay suppose
that I pick a random Quantum circuit
with let's say n qubits and you know N
squared Gates some some fixed polynomial
and N number of gates okay so I pick a
random such circuit and then I condition
on the event that the circuit is peaked
okay so I throw away the circuit unless
it happens to be peaked right and I just
I I I I only look at the peaked ones
okay and now my question is what does a
random peaked Circuit look like okay uh
so like like what kind of structure does
it have if any okay so so let me let me
give you sort of two extreme
possibilities just to to you know uh so
so one possibility would be that it
looks like this okay so you could always
get a peaked circuit as Eddie said by
implementing the identity right which
you could do by just applying any
circuit you like say you and then
applying is inverse
right so it could be that you know you
just you know a random Peak circuit just
looks like a very complicated
implementation of the Identity or of
some other classical function uh where
you know just by taking the gates in
that circuit and canceling them against
each other using a classical computer it
would be trivial to see what was going
on right to see that you know uh not
nothing too interesting was happening
okay now a second possibility would be
that a random Peak circuit will
by any official
officialism from just a uniformly random
Circuit of the same size okay so you
wouldn't you know with a classical
computer at least you wouldn't know it
is anything unusual about it or anything
special and yet if you ran it on a
quantum computer then it would just so
happen to choreograph the right
interference pattern in order to end up
at one of these Peak States
right uh now uh what what is the
relevance to verifiable Quantum
Supremacy well I care a lot sort of
which world is true okay because if this
second world was true then what this
would be telling us is that sort of the
these circuits uh that that we that we
want for verifiable NIS Quantum
Supremacy experiments are out there okay
at least they exist you know
platonically right it's you know we know
we want circuits that kind of look like
random circuits because those are the
kind that we you know we're we're you
know we know how to implement with 60 or
70 qubits but that you know actually
concentrate all their amplitudes
secretly on a particular outcome right
which we could then design a Quantum
Supremacy experiment around so for
example you know you know this would
then merely leave us with the problem of
how do we find such a circuit
efficiently right if we could find these
circuits efficiently then you know this
would give us our Quantum Supremacy
experiment namely I give you such a
circuit and you have to decide is this a
truly random Quantum circuit or is it a
random Peak circuit
right clearly a quantum computer could
solve that decision problem and you
would just see the answer when you ran
it you know you wouldn't need an
expensive classical computation and by
assumption a classical computer would
not be able to solve that problem yeah
all right
it's clear that um if it looked random
it would be robust
uh
robustness to noise right so yeah I mean
it's not that so so the thing that you
know you started with this notion that
we know how to implement random circuits
yeah
but but we also know how to implement
you know non-random circuits it's just
that they are not robust uh neither the
random ones nor the non-random ones yeah
yeah well I mean I mean one way due to
to to to to explain the or the question
is you know I would I would I would like
to know whether you know you can get a a
big Quantum speed up for some problem uh
without sort of doing some sort of
expensive encoding of a different
problem into that one but yeah that's
not a you know that that question is not
so easy to formalize right so I am
substituting the question of can you get
a big Quantum Advantage from a circuit
that classically you could not even
distinguish from a random Circle
okay so so I'm asking you know with a
Quantum circuit that looks random you
know that has no classically noticeable
structure to it right is that already
enough to see a Quantum Advantage okay
so so you know I mean of course you know
this is not the only possible approach
to nist Quantum Supremacy but I claim
that this is one approach okay uh and
and you know in some sense I'm asking
the question here that goes back to you
know the very beginnings of quantum
Computing Theory right of you know like
just how much structure do you need
right to get a quantum speed up right
and you know it's a question that you
know it's the question that I was trying
to address when I propose the
correlation problem
uh uh for example but you know that the
correlation problem still has too much
structure in a certain sense right and
so I'm asking like can we eliminate all
classically recognizable structure and
still have a quantum
so uh um
now a closely related question would ask
uh given an N qubit You Know M gate
random Quantum circuit
um how many more gates must we add on to
the end of it in order to get a peak
circuit right so so uh so so now like
I'm fixing the beginning of the circuit
right and I'm asking you know you know
you can add an appendix now right you're
you know your goal is to make the
circuit peaked using an appendix which
is as small as possible small as you can
make it okay how small can you make it
well it's clear that you can always make
you know your circuit Peak by adding m
word Gates how do you do that you you
invert right you just invert the
original circuit okay uh Now by using uh
results about you know random Quantum
circuits giving you T designs uh it is
possible to show that the number of
gates that you have to add onto the end
in order to get a a peak circuit you
know is at least a polynomial in the in
the original number of gates I think at
least m to the one-fifth power or
something like that okay but that's a
very weak lower bound right and I really
care like can you make the circuit
peaked with by adding only M over two
gates you know really anything uh much
less than M right and so you know this
is a way of asking like if I take if I
look at the output of my random M gate
Quantum circuit like uh does it have
sort of any interesting structure to it
right that you know that that say a har
random you know pure first they would
not have had other than just the obvious
thing that well I could invert the
circuit and go go all the way back to
the old zero state right is there
anything short of that yes during the
previous slide so you have started with
zero okay
these basis State seems to be for Speed
distribution and exponentially smaller
in the topology of those distributions
they are yes you can't just simply focus
on starting from zero whether you take
some kind of a random path through the
uterus and it kind of close to that zero
coverings yeah so so yeah so I mean I I
do think you know I think an excellent
way to think about this is in terms of
sort of you know paths through Hilbert's
space it's like you're starting at the
point all zero right and then you sort
of wander around randomly right and now
the question is uh uh now I want to get
back to something that I can recognize
as as as you know I'm not completely in
the Wilds of Hilbert's space right I I
you know I I need some state with some
efficiently classically recognizable
property right and now I could always
get back to such a state by just
retracing my steps just going back
exactly the way that I came right but
but that's not interesting right you
know so the question is is there a
better way to get back than that right
way where I've sort of taken a loop
right I you know and classically I
wouldn't notice anything special about
the the gates that make up that Loop but
if I run it on my quantum computer then
I can say that I have gotten to a
classically recognizable state
so that's the doesn't have to be the
Aussie arrested you know some some state
that has some you know on measurement
has some property that I could easily
tell it apart from just a random stick
my point was all right
yes you probably don't need bags you can
just that's right
uh sorry I don't understand
the pieces of the distribution yeah
very spots country to all the other
distributions yes so so from this
distribution
yeah yeah it's most likely if you are
close to it will be close to the zero
then some other states
I I don't think that's necessarily true
because just by counting there are so
many other more states that you might
get to rather than just the zero state
right maybe there would be some bias
toward the zero state right but there's
so many others that that you know you
know and and any of them are okay
yeah yeah and at least
amplitude amplification balance
um so so what would amplitude and
amplification give you here that that's
not clear to me okay
okay I mean I mean because Ron amp would
do an amplification at least as I
understand that you would have to run
the entire original circuit
but why would you have to do that
because you're trying to get to a state
that has a classically recognizable
property I don't know how to say it any
better than that right I I just I just
yeah sorry uh okay yes yeah so if you
have a circuit that's right yeah yeah
one option which is it's compressible
um the random circuits are compressible
yeah then and then you can do that yeah
of their random circuits are not
compressive
do we know that well I mean I mean a a
so there are these results that that say
that like circuit complexity increases
linearly right as you applied a random
circuit okay the uh um Nicole younger
Helper and you know and Jen's eisert at
all right have recently shown such
results which give you a sort of
incompressibility of randoms of of the
output states of random circuits so we
know that the measure of compressible
circuits is sort of approaching one
you mean the measure of incompressibles
yeah I mean I mean in a sense yes right
because you know you're just you're
picking each layer of gates
independently of all the previous
sliders right so you're just adding
entropy for each
yeah okay right I mean how I mean how
could it be compressible just by
accounting argument
I mean yeah the the I mean the
non-trivial question here is about the
output state of the surface right but
but you know that's what the younger
helper middle result pumps it up
but the other question is do you
do you need to be efficient uh do I need
oh well well again I'm trying to start
by asking the existential question okay
I'm just asking do these things exist
okay if they exist then we can ask the
next question of how do we find them but
it's not even clear that what I'm
looking for exists okay it's not even
yeah what about this technology space
you feel the space is flawed
if Hilbert's face is flawed then you
know Nobel prizes for all of us you know
I mean you know that that's way more
exciting than anything that I'm talking
about here and let's discover them right
right then you know then then you know
basically everything in this whole
conference is out the window and let's
uh let's go explore whatever that other
crew thing is
okay
so yeah
uh okay so yeah we can even ask what
fraction of quantum circuits or Peak you
know I have upward and lower bounds of
course it's an exponentially small
fraction but you know I would like to I
would like some tighter bounds uh you
know and then of course there is the
computational question so how hard is it
to sample a random Peak circuit but what
about just a peak circuit that is hard
to distinguish from random
okay so uh you know so these questions
can be addressed numerically so I've
worked with a uh uh recently graduated
uh uh uh a PhD student at UT Austin
named yushuan Zhang and so we have some
preliminary data where we like look for
you know random
um
um you know uh we looked at random
circuits on these numbers of qubits uh
with I think you know initially a
hundred layers of of random Gates and
then we we asked how many more gates
would you have to add on to the end of
these circuits in order to get something
peaked or to say it a different way fix
the number of additional Gates that
you're going to add on like let's say
it's 50 or it's 33 or it's 25 uh uh uh
uh uh uh uh layers of gates and then
optimize the peakness so up you know try
to make the output of the combined
circuit you know as peaked as possible
Right have a have some base estate
output with as large a probability as
possible and what do you get and and the
short answer uh uh at least from our our
you know and we addressed this using you
know local optimization heuristics right
to search for the the best possible
appendix that makes your circuit as
peaked as possible and and so there are
surprisingly Peak circuits that you can
find this way for example if I take a
hundred layers of gates you know on 12
qubits and then I just add on
um 25 more layers of gates like I can
get something where a single base of
state is output more than 10 percent of
the time right and we've examined these
circuits and we see no obvious structure
in them whatsoever okay they look like
they're you know at least to us like
they are just random circuits right
there's no obvious cancellations you can
do it looks like you're just randomly
wandering around in the Hilbert space
and then lo and behold somehow you end
up at this peak State okay so those
things seem to exist that's the good
news for verifiable Quantum Supremacy
but the bad news is that the amount of
peakness seems to be increasing
exponentially with n the number of
qubits yes
okay that's the that's the surprising
and interesting part right you can just
prove analytically that if you had if
you had a car random State then you know
there would be no short appendix that
you could add you know no short circuit
that you could add on to it in order to
measure any anything about it that would
differentiate it from the maximally
mixed state right this is this is you
know just by uh uh you know standard
tailbounce right you can you can you can
prove that sort of statement right and
you know and our numerical results are
consistent with that as well uh uh we
checked right but somehow in the outputs
of these random Quantum circuits there
is some kind of structure there that is
not shared by a har random state right
we don't know what it is you know we
don't know how to explain it but
numerically you find it okay that's the
good news the bad news again is that it
seems to Decay exponentially with the
number of qubits yes
it means that they're very slightly
compressible in any case yeah but yeah
we've done a lot of selections on the
appendix part okay there's the initial
random part which is not compressible
and then there's the part that we're
adding to the end which of course will
be a little bit compressible yes but we
always go back to the original state
that's right you could always do that
that's why it's so important here that
the appendix is smaller than the
original circuit right I know if it's
indeed yeah yeah even with the smaller
parts you can require that you end up
with the all zero State you well but but
that's not clear right I take a random
circuit without
it's not clear
with 50 Gates that I can add here put 50
layers that I can add to the end of it
that will get me to the ozone that's
just a one cubit depth Quantum circuit
that Maps any any basis state to any
other basis statement oh so no no no no
no that's not true you have this
entangled 100 Cube you know you have
this entangled incubid State you're only
allowed to apply unitary gates to it
right you can't just force a qubit to be
I know
all zero States yeah but that you could
do by inverting the original circuit
it's not clear that you can do it
anymore succinctly than that I'm sorry
okay I think it's called what uh yeah I
just don't understand what's wrong yeah
if you just wanted to match the map X to
Zero yeah and you can do it with one
layer and so if you have a superposition
the x is overrepresented then you can
get uh
oh yes yes yeah fine if you have
pinkness on one thing like X you could
always map it to peakness on a different
thing with your slightly more depth of
course that's true yeah and then of
course you have inverted your circuit
now they contested well yes yes I mean
again a peak circuit because of being
feet must be slightly compressible I I
agreed to that I said that okay yeah
what is your definition of random
circuit here uh you pick a bunch of
gates each one independently uniformly
around them okay you can have different
ensembles you know the diff you know the
differences between different random
circuit ensembles might be relevant but
you know um
right now I'm not you know you know I'm
not uh I'm not sure what difference it
will make so I'm not I'm not fit I'm not
I'm not fixing a choice right but we can
you know pick randomly you know sets of
qubits to apply the the the the the
gates too uh you know you fix a
universal basis of one and two cubic
Gates choose Gates randomly you know
independently from that basis uh and
yeah that's that that's it you know you
you could also consider spatially local
circuits right I mean you know you could
you could consider ensembles where
you're on a 1D line or a 2d grid you
know and that would give you a slightly
different question
that were those would approach basically
this uh two design feature which uh well
yeah so so Random we know that random
Quantum circuits give UT designs for you
know for for actually for arbitrarily
large dick okay those are very
non-trivial results that have improved
over the last
text okay
so so I wanted to
um
how many how many minutes of was that
that
a few minutes to to talk about you know
a a different approach to sort of
near-term quantum Supremacy that I am
hopeful you know uh can actually be be
done in the near future and this is uh
well you know wouldn't wouldn't it be
awesome if we could do a Quantum
Supremacy experiment that didn't depend
on any unproved computational hardness
assumption right well like you know what
what does that even mean right well it's
clear that you know we would have to
change the question that we're asking a
little bit okay but you know there is
one domain in which we have proven
exponential separations between Quantum
and classical complexity and that is
communication complexity right the
number of qubits let's say that Alice
has to send to Bob to you know allow Bob
to to decide some some function can be
exponentially less than the number of
classical bits that he would need to
send you know even in any randomized
protocol okay and we have you know
seminal results uh to that effect by uh
you know gavinsky Kempy you know Ron
Ross uh at all from uh a couple decades
ago uh you know wouldn't it be nice if
if we could you know experimentally sort
of demonstrate those results okay and
and in some sense what we would be
demonstrating is not that quantum
computers can give us an exponential
speed up in terms of you know
computation time Computing resources but
that they could give us you know that
sort of the a general Quantum state of n
qubits sort of requires an exponential
and N number of classical bits in order
to describe it right we want a sort of
direct experimental verification of that
claim about quantum mechanics which of
course is directly related to you know
the the central claims of quantum
Computing you know even if even if uh
slightly orthogonal to them
uh yes so good so there was work in 2018
uh which aimed to do exactly that uh
which used uh Optics to do it okay and
the main issue with that work is that
they they I think I had talked about
that on a future slide but but they they
they they they they they they
demonstrated a communication complexity
separation but in order to do it they
had to use an enormous number of optical
modes right the the the number of
optical modes would increase
exponentially with the size and so
they're not demonstrating that this you
know that sort of an entangled state of
incubants you know actually requires
exponential and end classical
information right and and and and and
now you know that is the claim that I
want to directly experimentally test and
you know and having run some numbers I
think that the hardware like you know
where you can now do two qubit gates
with 99.9 Fidelity and things like that
I think that the hardware is just now at
the point where this sort of experiment
ought to be feasible okay uh so
um
so uh um
you know the the uh uh classic
separation between Quantum and classical
one-way communication complexity use
this thing called The Hidden matching
problem where um Alice uh has an N bit
string X Bob has a matching uh uh on the
set from one to n the way that I always
remember it is you know Alice knows for
each of n people whether they're male or
female Bob knows who is dating who okay
and uh the goal is that you know Alice
has to send Bob a short message that
lets Bob figure out for any one couple
of his choice just whether they're
same-sex or opposite sex
okay uh now classically uh uh sending
square root of n Bits the Bob is
necessary and sufficient basically
because of the birthday Paradox you know
you know of course the the lower bound
was a non-trivial to proof uh quantumly
uh Only log of n qubits are enough for
this task okay because Alice can send
Bob a state like this one you know that
just encodes the whole end bit string in
superposition form and then Bob uh given
that state can measure it in a basis
like this which for each Edge and is
matching I and J has uh basis vectors I
plus J and I minus J and if he gets an i
plus J Vector then he knows that I and J
were a same-sex couple and if he gets I
minus J then he knows that they were an
opposite sex couple so that's the that's
the protocol
okay so uh uh recently in a paper just a
few months ago by me and Harry Berman
and William kretchmer uh we noticed a
new implication of this communication
complexity separation which is in some
sense could have been realized at any
point in the last 20 years or so but you
know I don't know why it wasn't uh we
say that that uh if you look at fbqp
which is the relational problems that
have polynomial time Quantum algorithms
okay and you give advice to that which
could be classical advice or Quantum
advice then Quantum advice is just
unconditionally more powerful than
classical advice right it is it is rare
in complexity theory that you just have
an unconditional separation between two
classes okay but that is the case here
uh and it's very different from the
situation if we were to look at decision
problems he's like I showed 20 years ago
that bqp with Quantum advice is
contained in post bqp bqp with post
selection and with classical advice okay
I also showed that post bqp is equal to
PP so that means that you can't separate
Quantum from classical advice on a
decision problem without also showing
that like you know bqp is different from
you know piece based or thing you know
huge things like that okay situation
with relational problems that have many
outputs is completely different okay and
we basically just used the hidden
matching separation to show this and
there's one additional observation that
you have to make which is that the
separation still works if Bob's input is
small so in a sense you can de-randomize
Bob's input and you know it doesn't have
to be an arbitrary matching you know it
can be a succinctly described matching
and the separation is still true Okay so
uh so so my proposal is basically to use
this kind of thing this separation
between you know Quantum advice and
classical advice with respect to uh
relational problems and demonstrate it
experimentally okay so you want to
prepare some end qubit States PSI uh and
then measure it where inside where the
measurement basis will only be chosen
after uh you know the state is prepared
right so there could be many possible
measurement bases and in some sense
nature at the time that it's preparing
Psy will not yet know which measurement
basis is going to be chosen you know
kind of like in the Bell inequality you
know experiments right you know won't
know and now you know we you know we'll
we'll pick a measurement basis you know
we'll repeat many many times with the
same state and with different
measurement bases we'll collect all the
results okay we'll we'll crunch them
with our classical computer and now
we're going gonna try to make an
argument that you know if we had any
secretly classical description of Psy
that was sufficient to explain all of
those measurement results then it would
have required an exponentially many
classical bits okay even for a
probabilistic description right and this
is exactly the kind of thing that
Community you know one-way communication
complexity lets you do for example maybe
with 20 qubits we'll be able to check
that any classical description of them
would have needed at least a hundred
classical bits okay or some you know
some number greater than 20 in any case
you know it's I don't think you know
because of experimental limitations it's
not going to be 2 to the 20th power
right but it could be something more
than 20. okay and um
uh yeah and and you could use the hidden
matching algorithm from the last slide
uh but you know I I think that to really
make this practical we want to design a
new one-way communication complexity
task that is specifically suited to you
know to do doing this with an experiment
okay so uh uh you know I think you know
you want to like do something like
linear cross entropy where basically
you're applying a random circuit to the
old zero estate uh you're then measuring
uh uh the output state in a basis that
is chosen on the Fly
um
and uh uh
um yeah if if you use hidden matching
then it could you know look like this
but I think you know the the the the
measurement circuit might just look like
you measure each qubit independently and
randomly chosen bases right or it could
even be we apply a second random circuit
okay and then you know the test of the
outcome could be some look something
like linear cross entropy benchmarket
right so it's like still random circuits
still linear cross entropy benchmarking
to check the outputs but the
interpretation of what we're doing is
now completely different right we're now
trying to show a communication
complexity separation okay and uh you
know I've talked to the people at
Continuum about this who uh you know uh
um you know uh you know it looks like
with you know you know 20 qubits with
you know 99.9 all to all Fidelity you
know you could do something like this
and I think it's great that you know
there is interest in doing this type of
experiment but uh what is lagging right
now is the theory you know we need not
just an asymptotic separation but we
need one that is tight enough that we
can get concrete numbers for let's say
20 qubits that would give us the
separation that we want
uh uh yeah so so another you know uh the
the last idea that I just learned uh uh
um a few weeks ago is uh you can verify
you could hope to verify random circuit
sampling by just you know repeating it
over and over and over again like
trillions of times and just looking for
a collision in the output right looking
for a you know the same output occurring
twice which takes exponential time but
because of the birthday Paradox the time
into a collision is only 2 to the N over
two right not two to the n and when n is
50 or 60 this might work uh so I worked
with Andrea Mari uh and a back of the
envelope calculation suggests that with
current Hardware you might have to run
for like a few months run your
superconducting quantum computer and
then you would collect enough collisions
that you could actually uh do
statistical analysis on it and have uh
evidence for Quantum Supremacy you know
without having to calculate a difficult
linear cross entropy Benchmark so
possibly worth it I'm not sure uh so you
know the the the question that I'm
always trying to ask here is sort of is
there a law of conservation of weirdness
that sort of for every problem that
admits an exponential Quantum speed up
there must be some weirdness in its
detailed statement which the quantum
algorithm exploits to focus amplitude on
the rare right answers you know how
non-wear can we make it all right so
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah can you go back to a Venn diagram
uh yes
there it is yes
oh there we go well I would like to say
that the qaoa also fits into the other
box with bozot sampling and random
circuit sampling of course the qaoa at
its shallowest depth has Supremacy on
random instances
and it's proof that exactly the same
level that you prove random
circumstances that is true but if we use
qaoa in that node then we give up on the
efficiently verifiable that's why okay
so then we're still back here we're
still not in here I agree with that
problem I think it's sort of fascinating
yeah
only the shallowest depth position
parameters
and you uh you actually will have
um anti-concentration and you'll be able
to prove that to happen
if you want to find a good string
meaning one whose energy is high then
you have to set the parameter to a
corner yeah
so the same algorithm at the same depth
has both those things depending on the
parameters
yeah yeah sure
I guess one question is like
I guess there must be some stuff I'm
missing or something because it's very
easy or maybe I think you adversarially
like a cryptographer but like
um it's very easy of course for me to
come up with something that produces
pollutants the same string twice that's
true how do I know that my circuit isn't
just doing that by accident sort of
that's true that's true no I mean I mean
yeah so this is this is not a way to
sort of get uh uh uh uh
um how to say it I mean I mean I mean
yeah you you could just substitute a
trivial circuit you know that is peaked
for example that always outputs the same
thing right but if what you were worried
about is you know was was specifically
that you know you are uh uh just uh uh
generating a uniform you know
distribution let's say which is you know
in practice as you know or you know
maybe the main worry right or one of
them then you know you could rule that
out right and you could even estimate
like the the degree of uh you know the
you could even estimate the Fidelity of
your circuit in this way right without
having to do the hard classical
computation so I thought I thought it
was It was kind of cute but yeah maybe
maybe it's not more than that no I mean
yeah
like sufficient confidence in your noise
model that I wasn't doing something
weird like that then you actually yeah
can be really confident something yeah
yeah yeah yeah no I mean like it's kind
of an obvious idea but then the
interesting part was like you could run
the numbers and you get out an answer
like it's on the scale of months which
is you know maybe doable right
yeah in your experimental results um
Pete circus yes did you get any sense of
the prevalence of those Peak circuits so
you picked a random
um yeah so so I mean I mean I mean in
some sense the the way that we're doing
it is like using local optimization to
look for a peak circuit so it doesn't
really tell you what fraction of
circuits are right right uh you know we
know that it's an exponentially small
fraction right that's not hard to prove
right uh we don't know exactly what you
know exponential fraction as I said I
would love to have better
events yeah
uh yeah just plug up uh to what extent
do you think this exponential decay is
because of like what it is of
optimization where is it that's a good
question like it could be that our
optimization is just not good enough
right but it could be that uh
I mean look you know you know you can
choose what to be surprised by right I
was surprised that there is any peakness
at all that's on to be defined here
right and you know I mean I'm surprised
that there is any exploitable structure
in the output of a random Quantum
circuit that differentiates it from a r
random state right and and you know and
and in some sense like like you know the
world feels saner to me right if if that
structure again exists but it decays
exponentially with the number of qubits
right if it if if it doesn't Decay then
that is awesome that's awesome news for
you know uh desk Quantum Supremacy right
and then you know then the circuits that
we want are really out there to be found
and we just have to figure out how to
efficiently find them
take a break yeah
thank you
[Applause]